how did you come up with like the
workout methodology that you used I
didn't train them the way I trained
because they didn't want to look like me
they didn't want to be jacked I had a
dude come in once he just started off
the conversation like hey to be clear I
never want to look like you and I was
like don't worry you never will
um I took a step back and I was like no
because like you don't overnight like
sneeze and become jacked there's like a
100,000 days between where you are and
where I am and you can just like stop
and I'm measuring you right now and you
don't have the determination to get
there I've weighed and measured you and
there's no way that you're sufficient